so I'm going to talk about probably the
culmination of about 35 years of
attempts to find something better than
floating Point arithmetic starting in
the 80s I think is when I started
working on this right now I'm
expatriated to University of Singapore
and they' provided a very good home for
me to work on this kind of research and
I appreciate that so why worry about
floating point I came up with a simple
example because I found out that
everybody trusts Matrix Matrix
multiplication they use it for examples
all the time well suppose just one row
in one column where happen to be this a
and that b so you were taking their
scalar product in order to find out the
result and these are fairly ordinary
numbers these are integers they're not
that big 32 million 1 negative 1 80
million 40 million no perfectly ordinary
reasonable numbers if you do this in
single Precision you'll get a. b equals
z which would tell you hey these vectors
are orthogonal
might be an important property to know
check it by doing double precision and
you again get A.B equals 0 and you know
what's coming uh let's suppose you do it
with a binary sum collapse where you
don't do it from left to right but you
do it these two these two and then add
them which often helps the the behavior
a little bit you get one and those two
numbers about as far apart as you can
get in terms of meaning and accuracy the
correct answer is actually two so most
linear algebra is unstable with floats
I'm always amused when I hear people
talking about uh like this method is is
is stable but this method is not
actually they're all unstable all of
them are can be made very sensitive to
Tiny changes in the input floating point
is as dangerous as all get out it is
just nothing but a
swamp and yet we get along with it just
fine because we're so used to it we've
suffered under it and we've just said
well you that's you got to learn to live
with it first of all my main objection
with i e 754 the standard from 1985 is
that it's not a standard it's a
guideline has a section of requirements
it has a section of suggestions
recommendations well people take those
or don't take those as soon as that
happens you're going to get different
binary output from every different
computer system actually the way that
the standard is set up you can get two
different answers from the same computer
running the same operating system just
doing it a few seconds apart there isn't
even consistency from one run to another
because it's affected by cash whether
you took something out of the out of the
88087 uh uh stack and put it in the cash
temporarily and then put it back
suddenly you got an overflow in one case
but you got a nice reasonable number and
the other that lack of guarantee is just
crippling if you're trying to debug a
system and you're getting different
answers on different systems the whole
idea of a standard is that you get the
same answer on every system the people
who conceived of java I remember James
goling was just horrified when he
discovered that using i e 754 was no
guarantee of identical results across
all platforms in Java when you make
mistakes in rounding errors of course
it's completely quiet they put in
something called the inexact flag which
every processor designer has to make
sure is maintained so if you get an
inexact or rounded result the flag goes
on inside the processor have you ever
seen a language that lets you see that
flag in fact the only way you're going
to see that flag is probably by getting
to the assembler and being very very
good with a debugger and being able to
reset the processor flag do an operation
then check the processor flag again it's
never been uh made mainstream and of
course it breaks the algebra law it's
like associative arithmetic a plus
grouped B plus C is not the same as
grouping a plus b and then adding C and
that means that compilers are not free
to rearrange numbers without changing
the answer but they do anyway of course
so does the distributive law also does
not hold there was even once a machine
that didn't have the commutative law
satisfied a * B was not equal to B * a
that was the cray one incredible that
was a real headache they they finally
fixed it by always sorting it so a was
less than b so you got the same wrong
answer every time and people were happy
anyway it overflows to Infinity if you
get too big of a number bigger than you
can represent what does floating point
do it says well let's just use Infinity
instead how stupid can you be which is
closer to a a big number infinity or you
know 10 to the 38th or whatever your
number
is I found out why this happens from
that man right there dick sites he
explained it to me when he was visiting
in Singapore it's the rule is round to
nearest
even well Infinity is an even number and
zero is an even number in in terms of
this so oh round to that one well think
about what you're doing because that
makes the answer infinitely far away on
a logarithmic scale uh there's no way to
express most of the real number line if
you think about it all you can do is
pick little rational numbers and say
everything's going to be close to one of
these but most of the real number line
is not n * 2 the minus
whatever so the key idea I came up with
a few years ago was to put a bit on the
end of the number right at the end of
the fraction that says is it exact or
not you see we've always had a way of
expressing infinite precision and
infinite decimal real numbers with a
finite set of symbols we've been doing
it for a long time if you want to say
pial 3.14 that's wrong but if you just
simply write pi equal 3.14 dot dot dot
after it you mean there's more decimals
after that that means it's between 3.14
and 3.15 it's not equal to either one if
it was equal to 3.14 you wouldn't have
needed the dot dot dot if it was an
infinite set of nines let's say after
the 3.14 that's the same as 3.15 and you
would have said that so all you need is
a dot dot dot or the absence of a dot
dot dot to mean there's more decimals
after this well that's the open interval
in between exact intervals and it's one
bit so just like you put a sign bit in
front of a number to say whether it's
positive or negative you put a UB bit
after the number to indicate whether
it's exact or in between exacts and
that's a very powerful idea that that
lets you get some of the trappings of
interval arithmetic and ballot methods
without having to have a pair of numbers
in order to represent everything let's
go back to i e 754 because I'm not done
hanging about it um the exponents are
usually too large and if you've built
floating Point Hardware you know that
it's easier to build an exponent than it
is to build the the fraction I think
this was really one of the big reasons
so these exponent sizes were decided by
committee back in the 80s people saying
I want a 16 bit exponent I want 11 bit
exponent and it was largely on what what
was easiest to design not what people
were actually using we've done some
studies at Lawrence Livermore that
indicate that almost never do real
application codes go much outside of 10
the 13th to 10 Theus 13th and yet we've
got hundreds of orders of magnitude
supported by the i e
standard so the accuracy is fairly flat
of course there's right I'll show you
the pictures of the wobbling accuracy of
floating point it's it's fairly flat
across the Vass range and then it falls
off off a cliff and there's probably a
better way to manage accuracy there's a
lot of wasted bit patterns you got both
zero and negative zero that means if you
want to check if x equals to Y you can't
just look at the bits you have to say
well if it's zero then check the first
bit can imagine that complicating just
check to see if two things are equal and
there's like five quintilian different
ways to represent Nan in double
Precision not a number I don't think we
need those there's a lot of other things
we could do with those bit patterns
subnormal numbers are a headache while
the Berkeley uh people come up with a
fairly clever way of adding a bit to the
architecture so that you don't have to
suffer quite so much with subnormal
numbers mostly it just adds a whole lot
of transistors and space to your chip
and uh you know the benefits are are
limited for most people divides are
always hard they're much harder than for
multiplication and decimal floats while
they're part of the standard there is no
32-bit decimal float it Go 64 and 128 I
think are the only sizes for decimal so
here's a quick introduction to the the
Unum format that I introduced in 2015 I
call it type one because there's some
variations and the the second variation
is so different um it it preserves the
idea of an uncertainty bit but I was
trying to do is doing the most gradual
thing imaginable i' take the i e
standard and add three meta fields to it
so you got the sign exponent and
fraction for I for i e and this happens
to be a half Precision float which is
five bits of exponent and 10 bits of
fraction and that was pioneered by
Nvidia and I think Lucas Films they
wanted something that they could store
some of their their video information
and it had just barely enough dynamic
range and enough Precision that it
wouldn't lose all the goodies out of the
movies but uh now it's being supported
in Hardware uh Nvidia started supporting
native 16bit half Precision floats and
in Intel has made the transition from
just supporting the format to actually
doing the operations with only 16 bits
so these are starting to come in Vogue
because they they look like they're good
for neural networks and that's all the
Precision you need to train a neural net
so I wanted to be upward compatible by
adding the the U bit on the end and then
a field that says how many bits of
exponent do you have and how many bits
of fraction do you have and of course I
have to set the size of that field but
in this case like a three bit exponent
size size and a 4-bit fraction size size
suffice to give me a big range of sizes
and this means that you track the amount
of uncertainty because where the
uncertainty bit Falls will tell you how
much range there is if it's in a very
low Precision a low order bit then
you'll know it's a very approximate
number but it's way off to the right
then you know you have precise number
and if anybody wants to know more about
this I'm not going to talk about it much
tonight but this is the reference that I
have at the bottom of the screen um it's
they keep running out of this at Amazon
I see that they're down to four copies
it's in its third Printing and it was
briefly in the in the number best number
one bestseller which sounds good until
you realize it's that's in the category
of number
systems but um there's 4,000 books in
number systems okay so it's something
here's one graphical way to imagine
floats um as discrete points on the real
number line and here I've got a five bit
float that still follows I rules believe
it or not you can really push these
things down if you if you are careful I
think I got it all the way down to four
once but uh there's the sign bit which
is all zero for the positive numbers and
one the red one for the uh negative
numbers and the hollow dots you can see
up there are the subnormal numbers
denormalized numbers they actually fall
below the smallest uh exponential type
number but uh anything which has two
ones for the exponent in other words the
exponent completely full the first one
is infinity and the everything else is
is Nan cases so this is what you can
represent with a five bit float and you
can see it goes like 0o one qu half 3/4
one one and 3/4 to finally gets up to
three and a half the next number
represents infinity and then after that
it's not a number not a number not a
number kind of wasteful so what happens
if you use my system with the ubit is
you can represent present the exact
values or the range between exact values
and that includes at the very last step
between four and infinity so this is
exactly zero between zero and a half
exactly 1/2 and so on so that system
allows you to cover the entire extended
real number line with very low Precision
but if you ask what is the square root
of two on this I'd say well that's
between one and 1 and a half it's that
open interval and you can calculate with
that and you can say mathematically
correct things
with without you know making true
misstatements about the value of a
number the the risk of all of these
types of systems is that the intervals
that you're bounding things with tend to
grow and that's why interval arithmetic
and any kind of bounded arithmetic is
tricky to use and has not caught on it
was invented in the late 50s by a
Stanford man I think it was uh Ray Moore
and it's been pioneered by several
Stanford people ever since then but it's
always been kind of a cult following for
Interval arithmetic because it's tricky
to use and one of the reasons I did this
is to try to make it easier to use so
type two UNS something I I had a flash
about about a year ago which is instead
of using the real number line from
negative Infinity to Infinity use the
projective reals which meet at the top
at plus or minus infinity so imagine uh
projecting a light at the top and it
will cast a shadow on the real number
line okay so Plus at the very top it go
either plus infinity or minus infinity
so you can Define these points uh within
certain parameters but one always goes
over on the um on the East and negative
one always goes directly on the west but
the numbers you put in between you have
a lot of flexibility which means you can
do a custom number system but one of the
key ideas is that it's has perfect
reciprocation if x is here it's Mirror
Image one /x is down here which means
you now have multiply and divide on
equal basis the same way that add and
subtract are equally easy you just
reflect you just because you can negate
something with unary minus now you can
reciprocate something with a unary slash
and it works perfectly so there's some
beautiful advantages for this and here I
I've shown you that I can do it with the
decimal lattice what's the catch well I
don't really have circuitry that does
this it's very tricky circuitry if
you're trying to do it with things like
shifts Ander operations so I I have to
resort to table lookup and table lookup
looks really good up to a certain
Precision because table lookup could be
incredibly fast these are not numbers
these are Pointers to numbers and so you
can manipulate pointers much faster than
you can manipulate the numbers up to the
point where you run out of memory of
course but I suspect we can get a lot of
ROM on chips so I still hope somebody
does these at least up to like 20 bit
Precision I I wrestled with this for a
year thinking if only we didn't have to
use table lookup if there was some
better way to do it well let me contrast
two calculation Aesthetics because
there's a lot of people out there
talking about approximate Computing as
the thing that's going to save us and
get us to excess scale which means make
Computing even worse than floating point
so that it can go faster and use less
power and make a lot of mistakes and
maybe be good enough and they've
explored to see what kinds of
applications are so tolerant of lousy
Computing that you can get away with
that trade-off well I think what they're
really reacting to is the fact that with
I standard they they did something was
fast and and good enough and yeah left
out some stuff and then they started
throwing in some rigor just a little bit
of rigor let's give them multiple
rounding modes so they can play with
different rounding modes let's give them
subnormal numbers so they can more
smoothly go to they did all kinds of
things to try to improve the quality and
get more verifiability well you can't do
that just a little bit or else you get
nothing right it's not completely
mathematical provable it still makes all
the mistakes with not following the laws
of algebra then there's the people who
want absolute rigor the people who do
interval arithmetic or they use Unum
arithmetic the way the way I like to see
it used um sets of real numbers can be
actually represented very precisely and
you can manipulate them as as as well as
you would do like with Mathematica or
Maple but actually still be doing
arithmetic but that's a whole different
aesthetic and as I say there's a lot
fewer people that are interested in that
kind of absolute perfection unless
you're designing a nuclear power plant
or you know trying to figure out how to
land the the space shuttle maybe people
don't particularly need that kind of a
special care they just want something
that's fast enough most of the time it
works especially if you're playing video
games let's face it you don't really
care if you lose a pixel here and there
when you're playing a video game but the
thing is if you mix those two Aesthetics
which is what we do right now with itle
floats you get neither it's not as fast
as it could be because it's got all this
garbage in it to try to help you out and
it's not rigorous because well it isn't
you got to go all the way to one or all
the way to the other so instead of doing
a proximate Computing I think we should
do floating points aesthetic but do it
right for the first
time so I call these things posits and a
posit I looked it up is a statement that
is made on the assumption that will
prove to be true true in philosophy and
that's a more polite word than guess as
I was calling these things guesses and
and William Khan got angry at me for
doing that so uh I'm calling them posits
now it's a little softer word but let's
face it it's not a provable number you
say I think this is the right number and
I'm going to work with it it's just like
you would introduce something
philosophically so here's some metrics
for number systems I've seen a lot of
papers saying here's a great number
system it uses all logarithms or here's
one that uses all rational numbers isn't
that cool but I never see them say what
are your metrics for comparing one
number system against another and
there's a lot of things we could use so
most of this talk is going to be about
what the metrics are for comparing two
number systems well there's accuracy
I've got a kind of a funny looking
formula there you might think accuracy
is well like relative difference so how
how far apart are they divided by their
size or something like that but on a
logarithmic scale if you if you think
about that it's actually the log of one
minus the log of the other which is the
log of the ratio and how many decimals
it is well you got to take another log
so if you work it out negative log base
10 of the log of the base 10 of the
ratio of two numbers is the number of
decimals of accuracy of two closely
spaced numbers so as I as I tile the
system with numbers that's what's going
to be my accuracy plot dynamic range is
easy it's the ratio of the biggest
number to the smallest positive real
number and uh if you take the log base
10 you get how many decades there are in
your system and you'd like it to be
symmetric about one but not it isn't
always that way what percentage of
operations are exact how often do you
let's say add two numbers and you land
exactly on another number in your system
instead of having to round it' be nice
if that happened a lot because maybe you
could do perfect computations for a
fairly large fraction of the time but
when they aren't exact how much did you
lose what how many decimals did you have
to round it by in order to get to the
answer that you could represent and we
can compile all of those and then we can
do like histograms or Scatter Plots or
whatever and compare two different
number systems think about the entropy
per bit if you had I'm imagining a bunch
of LEDs that are all the bits of a 64bit
number and they're flashing like crazy
as they represent every single floating
Point number in in a computer as it goes
by I'll bet you those exponent bits
aren't moving very much there's a whole
bunch of them that are just sitting
still all the time because you almost
never use 10 to the 300th power let's
face it and so the high order bits of
those are mostly wasted so they didn't
think about trying to maximize the the
uh the the meaning of every bit when
they design these things and finally I
think the real proof of the pudding is
to come up with some benchmarks like
evaluate this formula solve a system of
equations do an fft do the inverse fft
see how close it came to coming back to
the same thing do basic math Library
kernels and find out how accurate this
system is versus another system and the
main cheat you have to watch out for is
people can turn up their accuracy by
turning down their dynamic range right
you take more bits from the fraction you
know from the exponent and give it to
the fraction well let's see if we can do
better with than we do with floats
without having to do that so here is a
diagram of a Posite arithmetic format
format and you notice the only thing
that's got a solid vertical line is the
sign bit the others the division will
vary the regime bits is the Run of bits
that you have at the beginning like if
you have 1 one one 1 0 that would be
four represented by four ones and then
terminated by a zero if it was 0 01 that
would be -3 it's a lot like extra extra
large extra extra extra large I just
bought it just before I got here I went
to Orchard Supply Hardware and got some
steel wool and I was buying triple zero
steel wool there was double zero steel
wool and there was quadruple zero Ste
okay the number of zeros it keeps
getting finer and finer it's like
women's sizes same thing so that's how
the regime bits are defined the exponent
bit if there are any are simply a
positive an unsigned integer there's no
bias floating Point has to have this
funnyl looking bias that you have and
then there's the fraction bits which are
always a normalized that is there's
always a hidden bit so this works like
floating Point except for that funny
stuff in the beginning and I'll show you
where that comes from I didn't use the
ubit because I'd much rather if I'm
going to round every time I'd much
rather have that that last bit for the
fraction and get a little bit more
accuracy it will round after every
operation
but if you get too big of a number it
will round down to the largest
representable number not up to Infinity
so it doesn't make that mistake the es
is sort of the equivalent of the
adjustable exponent size and you can
have an es an exponent size of zero not
have one at all or one or two but you'll
see that a very few small number of
exponent bits gives you a a very large
dynamic range you actually have another
vertical line there and that's the end
and you haven't said anything about old
terms single precision I'm assuming
people will pick a size and it will be
16bit 32bit 64bit and that will be the
standard these are things that are
capable of being anything from three
bits wide to thousands but uh I I I I I
suspect the hardware is not going to
allow that flexibility I haven't yet I
have yet to meet a hardware engineer
that's willing to let everything be
floatable at runtime both the exponent
size and and the the word size so I
understand that so I assume that I'm
going to be beating floats at their own
game 16bit versus 16bit 32bit versus
32bit let's duke it out okay maybe I
should also bring out these numbers are
isomorphic so the pattern doesn't change
so if you yeah except for the es so if
you fix the es if you do a 16bit number
and a 64-bit number the beginning Parts
look the same so you take a 16 bit
number and extend with zeros it'll be
the same value in 64 bits that that's
the amazing thing is that adding bits to
the right actually increases both the
accuracy and it also increases the
dynamic range which is kind of
mind-blowing how can that possibly be
you think like fractions it works that
way but it doesn't work with with
dynamic range here's an example just to
see how it would work here is a sign bit
is zero so that's a positive number same
as floats regime bits 0 01 in this case
the UC which is 2 to the 2 the 3 or
256 is uh there's three regime bits that
terminated by a one so that's 256 Theus
3r power then you multiply it by the EXP
bits which is represents the number five
one1 so it just scales up by five and
now you finally got the scale factor so
it's a floating Point number in the
sense that it's a power of two times an
integer but the integer in here in this
case is you know uh 221 over 256 with
the hidden bit and I think that if you
can build a float out of conventional
circuitry then it should be very simple
to build this as well it's going to be
simpler because I'm going to strip out a
whole lot of the exceptions that you
have to wrestle with with i e and they
don't overflow and they don't underflow
so you certainly don't need those flags
and there is no Nan representation it's
not a number right why are you assigning
a number to something that's not a
number it's it's fundamentally illogical
if you are Computing something and you
get a nonsense operation like 0 divided
by 0 the right thing to do is stop and
report it or interrupt and let the
interrupt Handler say I don't mind uh
substitute this and go on whatever it is
you don't keep wasting energy and time
by Computing something at this point
where you've got garbage you report it
back to the user and let them do
something about it so if you take out
the Nan wow does that simplify a lot of
stuff so this should be simpler smaller
and faster circuits than i e uh
754 let's go back to that projective
real number line because I want to show
what Isaac was just mentioning about now
about how you just add bits and you can
increase something I'll pick a u seed of
four which means uh the exponent size is
one so two to the two to the one is four
and you'll see why these work out so
elegantly
now that looks a lot like type two units
and that I've got perfect reciprocation
and you will always get perfect
reciprocation for powers of two also
zero is exactly one over plus or minus
infinity and backwards so those those
work out just great you just take the
two's complement of everything but the
first bit in order to take the
reciprocal oh uh yeah if you have
something on the left- hand side and you
say well that's a negative uh two's
complement number so flip it over notice
that the the the what you're
representing will be negative but flip
it over and then I'll be talking about
the pattern of bits from that that you
get on the positive right hand side so
if you're inserting a number between
let's say the four and the infinity you
factor another factor of four so now
it's up by 16 four times bigger down at
the bottom if you're between 1/4 and
zero it's 1/16th so if anytime you're
you're interpolating between infinity
and your biggest number you make it you
multiply it by the U so it keeps on
getting bigger and bigger as you get you
know like like the Doomsday Clock very
very close to
midnight and uh if you're between if
you're between let's say 16 and two well
you can put a power of two in there so
that means I'm going to be adding uh uh
well I's see that I already did that one
between four and one now that's that's
more than one U seed Factor but it's
it's a it's a power of two so I can put
a power of two in there which means now
we're looking at exponent bits and the
exponent bits are showing up in blue
here so I've got gold regime bits
followed by Blue exponent bits and
that's the rule for doing this uh as a
recursive thing when you finally
actually get something like between one
and two the only thing you can do is now
interpolate it linearly so three halves
goes between one and two and three goes
between two and four and you see the
fraction bit shows up in Black at the
end and I know this s sounds very
complicated but it really is nothing
more than floating point that takes into
account whether you're doing geometric
increases or linear increases
automatically so if you round a number
let's say between 4 and 16 I give you 12
well it would take it would use the
geometric mean as with the number that
goes in there instead of the arithmetic
mean so that's actually a better way of
rounding but you don't have to do any
special Hardware it's just the same
thing as you would round normally except
don't round to infinity and don't round
to zero but the cool thing is as you add
bits you add a zero to something it
doesn't change it if you add a one so
it's in in between two then you get this
extra accuracy and you get more dynamic
range of the North and the South it gets
bigger and smaller and on the right and
the left it gets more accuracy there's
something fundamentally logical about
this it just looks looks right to me as
opposed to being cobbled together so
here's a metric based study and I I'm
going to pick a number I I I have to
wrestle between doing a realistically
large number and doing one where I can
do every single possible case and study
it if I have an 8bit float or an 8bit
posit then there the uh the addition
table is going to have
65,536 entries because I've got 256 by
256 possibilities I can study the errors
of every one of those and I can show
them to you on the screen so that's
where I picked let's say a quarter
Precision I float not that there really
is such a thing in the official standard
is a quarter Precision float maybe there
should be but s bit four exponent bits
and three fraction bits seems to be kind
of true to the aesthetic and it's got a
dynamic range of five orders of
magnitude and two ways to represent zero
unfortunately and 14 ways to say not a
number here's what the frequency the
float accuracy looks like if you plot it
it has tapered accuracy and that off
from the left you see it tapers down to
zero now over on the right it had
gradual underflow in other words but it
doesn't have gradual overflow that's
where all the nans are they missed a
trick when they the committee met they
didn't realize that all this stuff about
tapering towards zero has a perfect
analog on the other side that they could
have used they could have had tapered
accuracy on the other side as well so
remember remember these numbers um
average is 1.4 decimal of accuracy and
maximum is 1.55 and I'll show you what
posits look
like there's pauses the maximum is 1.86
decimals the same eight
bits but there are seven orders of
magnitude expressable it's much
wider it doesn't seem like this is
possible but yes you can be both wider
and higher at the same time let me put
both graphs on top of each other and you
see there's a couple places where the
floats actually exceed they stick out a
little bit by the way we're Distributing
all these slides those people who are
taking pictures of the slides I think we
can get you a copy if you want probably
much resolution better resolution than
your camera but uh asks you to put your
slid give them to him and he'll he
already have I mailed them to them
yesterday right they'll be on the
website great so you can see that it
over on the right I can express numbers
that the floats can't and uh for the
very small numbers possibly floats do a
little bit better but most of your
calculations are are in the vicinity of
plus of of the unity right ratios so
that's where most calculations occur and
I noticed that computational scientists
everywhere scale their problems they
don't always work with let's say
avagadro's number or planks constant so
everything is 10us 34th they they scale
things through so things are back in the
range of understandable numbers so I
think we're ready for round one round
one un unary operations we're going to
take reciprocals square root of x X2 log
base 2 of X and 2 to the X all one input
one output and how well do we
do well here's
reciprocation the floats make an a bunch
of errors on all there's 256
possibilities and I found out whatever
the error is and sorted it from smallest
to largest I did the same thing for the
posits you notice that the posit curve
in a magenta is always underneath the
float curve it's always better and in
the right hand side it's much better
because the uh the are that are made by
floats are infinitely large floats get
13% exact and composits get almost 19%
exact results so already it it goes a
little farther before the the the the
magenta leaves the uh x-axis at all and
of course there's no overflow and
there's no Nan I mean even one over Z
turns into plus or minus infinity and
that's a perfectly closed operation so
there are no exceptions to reciprocation
so that's already looking a lot better
behaved than
floats what about the square root only
slightly more exact 7.8% exact versus
7.03 but the real story is that curve of
what is the error when you do make an
error how bad is it and you can see that
the uh the cumulative error going from
from left to right is is much lower for
the posit than it is for the
floats I think it gets really
spectacular for X squ look look at that
it's not only you know 15% exact versus
13% exact but when floats get it wrong
they really get it wrong whereas this
this Dynamic Precision where it's
tapering will try to accommodate very
large and very small numbers it will do
a much better job of doing something
right with those numbers and not getting
it just uh totally giving up and once
again they've got look at that 12.5%
underflow and 25% overflow that's a lot
of cases to be throwing away when you're
just squaring a number this is the what
one of the reasons that people uh have
libraries for even doing like complex
arithmetic if you take a * B minus B * C
just to do complex arithmetic people are
paranoid that they're going to get
overflow or underflow when they take a *
D and that costs a lot of time in a math
library trying to fix that here's the
closure under the
log and once again pod are more
frequently exact log base 2 of course is
not maybe the most common thing you'd
ask for but you can derive natural log
and L base 10 simply by multiplying that
by a constant so all the math libraries
for all the different kinds of
logarithms usually start by Computing
the log base 2 and then they scale
it why is U you're always saying that
the exact is more for posits than for
floats the inexact is always greater
also why is that do you say the inexact
is greater mostly it's taking it away
from the nans and the exceptions so
instead of saying oh I give up it's
overflow or it's underflow I I will give
you an answer and so I'll get more
exacts as well as more exacts and then
it didn't throw a gutter ball and say I
give up that's what happens with with
floats is they give up on too many of
the of the numbers and they don't give
an answer at all where do the NS come
from let's see in the uh log it's all
the negative
numbers and why isn't at 50% okay so you
get a certainly if you try to take the
log of plus or minus infinity that's
going to be an n and in my case log of
zero is not representable because I
don't have minus infinity all by itself
so I call that an N I stop
I can do the interval right next to zero
but I can't do exactly zero it would be
a lie to say it's plus or minus infinity
i' get I get big mistakes if I then
exponentiated it so that's I think
that's the the simplest explanation
Here's 2 to the X which is you know
making numbers very big very fast it's
kind of funny that it still doesn't give
up and Round Up To infinity even though
it's a huge number you know if I take
the biggest number to the power the
biggest number that's awfully big but it
still says no round it
down well it's it's better than rounding
to Infinity but I just lost 1,233
decimal of precision but that's better
than infinity so that works out pretty
well okay ready for round two now here's
the fun part because now we're finally
going to do arithmetic plus minus times
divide of course we don't need minus
that's that's perfect but times and
divide are definitely a little bit
different so I'll do those separately
I'm going to show you kind of an eye
popping diagram because what I do is
what I call a closure plot I'm going to
color code what happens so you can see
the entire set of 65k 64 K values at
once so just brace yourself because
black means
exact magenta means an error blue is
underflow red is Overflow and yellow
means not a number
indeterminate that's what addition looks
like with floating Point arithmetic so
you can see the little kind of
the the little bevel down there in the
left lower left and the upper right
where it overflows you can't underflow
with with addition you can underflow
with a lot of things but not addition
so that doesn't happen so there's no
there's no blue here but it's kind of a
pretty pattern the uh the Stripe from
upper left to bottom right is really
subtractions because uh you can't see it
because it's so small but the smallest
reel is on the bottom left zero Max real
and Max negative Max real zero to
positive Max real so you're taking
differences along that diagonal and
you're taking sums along this diagonal
and it it's more likely you're going to
wind up with a a small number that you
can represent if you take a subtraction
but you see 70% are inexact 18.5% are
exact you're ready for the posit diagram
I'll go back and forth between so you
can compare them but try to remember
this diagram I'll show you what it looks
like for
posits okay well just about all the nans
went away so did all the all the
overflows and all the underflows there
it wasn't any underlow but you see what
I'm saying it here's here's what it was
and there's what it is with posits
there is an N you'll never find
it it's right here that little yellow
dot that's where you add plus or minus
infinity to itself that's the only thing
that causes an interrupt and says I
can't go any further I don't know what
that is so 25% of the cases are exact
now if you have ever tried to design a
dynamic number system that has a lot of
orders of magnitude addition is the hard
part multiplication is easy to get
closure right because you're scaling
over an exponential series it's just
natural to make that work but trying to
get the ads closed is really really the
trick and I think I've got something
that's considerably better than than
with floats here if I sort all 64k
losses from left to right and graph them
you can see posits win uniformly
everywhere and they don't go to Infinity
of course they the maximum addition loss
of of accuracy you get is.3 decimal
that's the worst thing that can happen
to you that's where you add the maximum
real to itself you get twice the maximum
reel and you round it back down so
you're off by a factor of two which is3
decimal all right let's Dy
multiplication and multiplication plots
no matter how many bits of precision you
use all have these big Corners cut off
because that's where they overflow and
they also have a diamond in the Middle
where it underflows it's not a perfect
diamond because gradual underflow so
that's a little bit rounded in you can
accommodate some of those those numbers
but uh this is where floats finally beat
me for the first time they got
22.2% exact numbers I only got
18% but look at the cost look at all
those oops those those overflows and
underflows it's knocking out almost one
quarter of the cases are just you're
going to get garbage
whereas posits just don't give up they
return an answer it's a meaningful
answer with a lot of decimals so I'm
willing to pay a slight price in the
number of exacts for getting that kind
of closure in
general now that's the sorted losses and
actually posits are much more robust
than than floats at retaining
information throughout a calculation and
not going completely off the
rails so the division plot it looks a
little bit like a permutation of the
multiplication plot there's a little bit
of a cemetery you see there because I
obviously X over y it doesn't have a
corresponding y overx symmetry you have
with with commutative
multiplication but uh you get plenty of
Nan values here always forms that Yellow
Frame around around the uh the float
diagrams you get do some slight
asymmetries here's what it looks like
for pauses and I didn't think it would
show up on this screen but it's almost
symmetric you see a little yellow dot in
the center yeah that's 0 divided by zero
that's the only thing that stops you is
so in very tiny fraction of cases do get
an N from 0 divid by 0 other than that
it just keeps going you go back yeah
let's go see it here here wh it seems to
be diagonal symmetry is it actually
there there's diagonal symmetry yes
because uh that's about whether they
change the sign right plus over plus is
the same as minus over minus but you
other than that it's uh you don't have
you don't have symmetry about
reciprocation about one so it's if you
get the U the actual PDF of this talk
it's kind of fun to really stare at this
very Out close it's it's it's a like I
say it's kind of an eye popping chart
but I believe having the hidden bit
equal to one all the time is going to
simplify your Hardware it's just always
one that's really nice it's like the old
days when they didn't have subnormal
numbers to deal with and and hard most
most Hardware Engineers really like that
situation so finally round three High
higher Precision operations let's take
these things out for a spin see what
they can do now I made up at least one
very simple formula evaluate this
formula and tried it out on 32bits so I
could say if you had a budget of 32-bit
values you couldn't cheat and use a pair
of them you have to always stick to
32-bit values how well can you do to
evaluate that expression up there see
that 27/10 minus E over Pi minus the sum
of Ro < tk2 + < tk3 all to the^ of 67
over 16 just a madeup formula I made it
up to be a little bit mean because
obviously 27 over 10 is kind of close to
2.71828 so I just know I'm going to
scrape off a couple decimals right away
and a lot of people don't know it but
root2 plus root3 is really close to
Pi you can figure out that by inscribing
a hexagon
superscribed out root2 plus root3 is
3.14 and then some so I'm going to
scrape off three decimals in the
denominator like I say I'm feeling mean
because I know what that's going to do
to floating point and it's going to do
it to me too actually if I try to do it
with pauses you take it to the 67 over
16th power just to make sure you know
how to take powers and taking things to
Powers tends to inflate uh erors as well
so I guess we shouldn't be too surprised
that an i e 32-bit float on the top line
which nominally has 7.4 decimals of
accuracy Al it wobbles a little only
gets three decimals right and of course
you don't know how many decimals you've
got right it reported all these decimals
but only the 302 is right after that
it's it's off in the weeds so the eror
is
0297 now if you're going to do interval
arithmetic to be fair that's a pair of
16bit numbers right you don't get two
32-bit numbers you get a pair of 16bit
numbers to fit in there that's your
budget and look at that answer oh my God
this is why people don't use interval
arithmetic it's somewhere between 18 and
33,000 usually you get something like
it's between minus infinity and infinity
this is actually a pretty good answer
for Interval arithmetic and that's the
last time people use interval arithmetic
they try it once they said that's fine
I'm going to go back to using floats
but uh that's a very big range of 3.3 *
10 4th now type one unms I think are
still unrivaled in terms of their
efficiency at representing an interval
that's closed because it gets 302.7 five
to 30 303 is a pretty tight interval
0.25 and that uses only 32 bits per
number by being flexible and growing up
and down uh you really can't beat that
that one uncertainty bit but the
designer say ah it's variable size can't
stand variable size can't keep track of
it we don't want to have a heap to
manage the sizes we don't want to expand
it out to the maximum size just give a
fixed size numbers okay done I heard you
type two and type three are are that way
now type two UNS I can craft the lce to
be really good uh for the for the
decimal numbers because like I say you
can customize the lattice to be whatever
you want just as long as you follow
certain rules and I can actually get
five decimals of accuracy three or 2.88
before it goes bad but with posits using
an exponent side such that I have the
same dynamic range or actually bigger 3
* 10 144th power no one can say that I
cut down the dynamic range in order to
get more accuracy bits I've got both
I've got six decimals of accuracy 32.8
A2 but if you let me reduce the exponent
size so I do get a little bit more
accuracy and does I don't I still got an
a dynamic range of 10 to the 36th power
on the bottom
line I've got 10 decimals of accuracy
from a 32-bit number
that's like the maximum you can get out
of a 32-bit number even if it was an
integer right I mean four billion is an
integer that's a 10 bit that's a 10
digigit number so posit speed floats at
both dynamic range and accuracy and
that's what I got out of just this
formula of course that's just one
formula let's try solving ax equals B
and usually you'd probably do that with
double Precision numbers but I'm going
to use a really small system of only 10
equations so I'm actually going to try
to do that with 16bit numbers and it's
exactly by the rules of linpac if you
know the rules of the top 500 scoring
they fill a a matrix completely full of
it's a dense Matrix with random entries
between zero and one then they sum the
rows and and make that the right hand
side so that nominally the correct
answer is one one one one one11 one but
you you solve it by Galaxy elimination
you compare how close is your answer to
just a series of ones and that's how you
know whether your computer system is
working when you build a really big
supercomputer because usually the first
time you run it it's not a series of
Once is something wildly wrong but it's
a good error check but it's also become
of course the the thing that scores all
the all the world supercomputers even
though it doesn't really relate to any
real applications anymore it's not often
you want a million bym million system
all completely populated not not sparse
but uh I use the complete I use the
classic La pack method which is Lu
factorization with partial pivoting so
I'm always picking the biggest element
of every column to use as a pivot
element and you can see with with i e
16bit
floats dynamic range of 10 12th the rot
mean square error was
011 and I got 1.96 decimal of accuracy I
tried it with posits I can do a whole
bunch of these statistically uh I just
picked an example the ran square error
is
0.0026 so it's five times four times
better and I got 2.58 decimals of
accuracy I call this beating floats at
their own game floats are supposed to be
good at some things like solving ax
equals B you do not want to try solving
ax equals B with intervals they blow up
and everybody does they say oh I've got
the Cal arithmetic let's try using Gussy
elimination bad idea explos now here is
a totally unfair example that I picked
out I'm going to admit that it's unfair
but I did get it from somewhere else
it's from what every computer scientist
should know about floating Point
arithmetic which is a real classic by
David Goldberg um in Computing surveys
from 1991 still worth reading um very
good explanation in a few pages of what
you should know about floating Point
arithmetic it's this like buckling
concrete you know you're going to pop up
the concrete by just very slight thermal
expansion and so these sides are only
the big side is seven and these sides
are 7 Hales 3.5 plus 2 Theus 111th
power so I should be able to do this
with quad Precision floats because quad
Precision floats have 113 bits of
significance if you include the hidden
bit so with I'll do it with 128bit I
floats and I'll do it with 128bit
deposits just to show you I can scale up
to any size just like float scan the
answer that's correct to 36 decimals at
least is figured by Mathematica with
extended Precision is as shown here I
don't expect you to remember that but
it's pretty easy to remember the 3.14
part because by coincidence I landed on
a p like number times 10-
16th so here's what you get with i e
quad prision floats one decimal
correct it's off by about
15% and of course it's as I say there's
no indication that it's off because you
don't have any kind of ubit to tell you
by the way you really screwed up here
and you don't know anything about the
number past the first decimal that's a
you know that's an awful lot of Labor to
produce just one one bit or one decimal
of accuracy with 128 bit posits it
gets in binary it got exactly the same
answer as you get from rounding the the
other one to 36 bits 36 digits so it
landed on it and if if you wanted to do
that with itle floats you'd have to jump
to octuple
Precision I can shave down the size of a
posit by any number of bits and I found
that by when I got to9 bits I was still
getting the right answer for this 118 it
starts to get shaky but I can that's
kind of the contest is 256 bits of float
119 bits of posit so you can see if you
can save all that bandwidth save all
that memory you're going to save energy
and power and the memory wall is going
to be not so bad you're going to make
better use of those bits so remember
this from the beginning the scalar
product
A.B uh you always get this right in
posits if you can represent those
numbers and to represent the numbers 32
million and so on you only need is 25
bit posits the reason that that 25 bit
suffices is because fused operations are
part of the posit definition fused
multiply ad is part of the definition
fused dotproduct
infus dotproduct you do all the
multiplies and place them where they
would be scaled appropriately so you're
doing like a great big sliding floating
Point accumulation it maybe uh 400 bits
wide 800 bits wide but the amazing thing
is it's faster than if you round after
every operation three to six times
faster all it costs you is a few bits
inside the CPU to accumulate as the
accumulator there is no reason in the
world not to have a fuse dot product
there was when it was patented which the
patent expired two years ago all R
coolish over in Germany patented this
thing and tried to get money for it I
think that prevented people from using
the exact dot product although IBM
bought a license but now that it's
expired it's high time to put it back
into number systems because now you can
do Matrix multiply with complete
confidence and know you're within one
unit in the last place after you do the
rounding because you only do one round
at the very end so if you have much less
rounding and it's three to six times
faster I've got the reference there bian
colen and Jack kig at the at UC Berkeley
have got the the circuit working for
this then there's just not much of any
reason not to use it uh 800 bits on a
chip is nothing these days
right so in summary posits beat floats
at their own gain which is guessing
their way through a calculation as best
they can and minimizing the rounding
error it's better accuracy it's better
dynamic range and it's better closure I
believe we are completely obsoleting
floating point I can't see a single
reason to make a new chip that uses
floating point when you could do this
instead show me a place where floats
don't do a worse job are harder to
design take up more space on the
chip I mean they have absolutely no
advantages as long as there's been a
tradeoff the float people have been able
to defend well yeah you're better at
this but I'm better at this so let's
just keep things the same if you're
uniformly better with a different method
and it does the same type of problems
and all you have to do is drop in the
value and it works exactly like a float
did you don't have to know anything
about interval arithmetic or any of the
other mathematics all the same
algorithms work they just work better
then I think it is time to replace i e
floats with posits so I wonder who's
going to be the first person to produce
a chip with positive arithmetic I have a
very strong suspicion it's somebody in
this room in fact they're in the back
row they're already working on it Rex
Computing is here and uh they're in
they've got their first silicon back and
they're testing it but they're planning
for a second batch of silicon that at
least will offer the alternative of Unum
arithmetic so you can imagine a mode
where it says let's just just do i e
Floats or in this mode use uh use the
posit type style so I think that's going
to give us the ability to pack more
floating Point units onto a chip the GPU
people are going to love that right
because they are taking up a significant
amount of silicon just with their with
their floating Point multipliers and
adders so if I make their fpus smaller
and they can suddenly pack a bunch more
into that real estate they're going to
really be interested it could be like a
30% maybe a 50% gain in the number of of
uh GP use you can get and I presume that
the power consumption is going to go
down as well because they're not having
to do all this testing for for nans and
so on now at the end my able assistant
Dr Yamoto is going to try to do a live
demonstration of these things using
Julia he's implemented them in Julia
which is uh a very fast but high level
language he's even got an audio thing
where we did an fft both with floats and
with posits so I hope you can get this
to work yeah all right so let's let's
give this a shot
so a couple things about this particular
implementation um it's not backed by I
floating points everything is done as
binary operations on on uh 64-bit
unsigned integers so there are a couple
places where I cheat and tell that it's
a signed integer for example to check
signs but the hardware doesn't really
treat it any differently okay so um I
don't know how many of you guys are
familiar with the Julia programming
language if you ever do any sort of
mathematical modeling and numerical
modeling it's a really great language
for it um it lets you and in particular
what's important about this is about
Julia for this this project is that it
lets you redefine all of all of your
create your own numerical types they're
first class citizens and you can
basically plug them in anywhere you want
you can overload all the operations in
such a way that if there's a builtin um
if there's a built-in algorithm to do
something you can usually like for
example matrix multiplication was a big
one you can usually go directly and just
immediately have matrix multiplication
once you've once you've implemented plus
uh minus and um and uh and
multiplied I think they're still you
guys got it
going we reversed this really we did
let's let's try this let me if I unplug
and plug back
in uh desk HDMI 2 I think it was
oh vj2 sorry
vj2 oh
no oh there we
go okay and then we'll just
move all right so this might be a little
bit tricky because I'll have
to do it this way okay so let's fire up
Julia
um so I'm going to import the sigmoid
number pack package which uh which is so
all of this is open source on GitHub um
so you should be able to um you should
be able to uh uh uh get this if you um
if you also if you also get Julia I made
sure I was not under any kind of inal
property agreements when I did all this
so I could give it away under the MIT
open source license right we're sticking
to that so um first uh we we'll do what
so I'll um create a a type which
corresponds to uh an 8bit posit with one
es
oops and uh let's take a look at what
the number one looks like in this
representation so you can see that the
sign is zero but um this may be a little
bit confusing because so it's legit 8
Bits it's secretly backed by a 64-bit
integer in the system but it will only
tell you that there's there's eight
there but if we want if you want kind of
a better description of what's going on
you can uh call it with a spacer and
what that'll do is it'll it'll it'll
show you the um the uh sign bit the um
the un uh regime bit regime bits um a uh
the es the exponent bits and then the
last four digits are the fraction um if
you want to see something like
256 uh maybe that's too big 16 let's for
eight bits let's do 16 you can see that
the size of the uh the size of the
regime has gone gone up it's still a
unary it's a unary number that
corresponds to two to the 2 to the 3 or
two the two to the 2 the zero is a flag
the zero that's a that's a that's um so
the first zero is second zero the second
zero size a flag ends so if I so okay so
let's do 32 that that will turn that
into a
one you always have to flip the bit so
it's r r r not R so in in this case
remember we're we're in the esze
environment one so that means that for
each of these unies the the exponent
goes up by two so in order to get to
that exponent of two that's in between
say two and eight or actually sorry one
and four or four and eight you need to
have another bit that that that turns on
those on those
exponents okay so let's do some slightly
more substantial uh you like a chair uh
no it's fine sure yeah okay P one of
three so just to prove to you that this
system like is can actually do some
arithmetic um you know that works uh we
can also do an
ADD and we can also do a divide um now 8
Bits is not very much resolution so this
will report as5 9 375 which is the
closest representable Value to 6 which
is what you would expect um let's do uh
let's do a slightly bigger
system oh thank
you H and then we can do uh let's do the
same thing as before except do this in
P2 and you can see it gets much
closer uh at the moment I don't permit
that I want you to I mean this is kind
of supposed to be like a hardware type
uh emulation and that's really
discouraged certainly languages could
promote for you just like they do single
Precision to double all right so if you
want to take a look at what this looks
like oh let me add
spacers um you can see that the this is
the representation of this number um all
broken up and you can see that um you
can see that uh there's a long fraction
bit with repeating decimals it's
currently around running to nearest even
which is why the last one is is a zero
instead of one and it breaks the pattern
of the repeating
decimal okay um just for reference we
also have uh in this Library we can also
do uh we can do this control rounding uh
controlled rounding no there's only one
rounding mode uh I I have actually
implemented more than one rounding mode
because they're useful for the valids
you need them for valids but if you're
going to do posits there's only one
rounding mode you don't have to have
four or five or six rounding
before you go on yeah now the 32-bit
number that ended in a zero what would
the value of that number be if that
ended in
one
uh I'm sorry it would it be bad would it
be bigger by two
uh yeah okay let's let's let's let's
let's let's do that oh no no it just
rounded that value yes but what
if try get converting point
6 in other words is it always zero no no
no oops all
right that should be farther from 6 I
mean I'm not going to do the math but
it's farther from point 6 than the other
one okay
excellent um okay so let's do something
maybe real uh so you didn't convince me
you made that last
Z I'm sorry to versus you were asking to
make it one larger you made it one
smaller yeah no but I wanted to know if
that very last zero at the top of the
screen it'll be slightly larger than 6
it'll be a little harder than be another
cuz the cuz the one with the zero is is
is 6 1.9 so that'll make it farther away
do you still want to see it but when
does it become
one when does it become one round and
that's what I was trying to understand
only previous round is only when it's
the exact tie it has a choice between
zero and one it's halfway in between I'm
sorry actually in fact this one isn't
halfway in between so round to near you
don't use the round to near even
semantic at all you just round it ask
question asking what's next instead of
next to X can you increment the binary
by one and transform it back into a real
I don't know if you had that
facility yeah that's what I'm okay there
you go okay okay all
right
um all right so let's let's do
this so I'm going to go into 32 comma 2
and I'm going to create a random array
of of numbers that are either one zero
or negative one if I can find my
cursor uh and make 6,
65,536 of these
numbers okay and I'm now going to
convert those into uh into into um
posits 32 comma 2 posits if you look at
find p uh
p p
do and you can see that those are all
those are all posits that are either one
zero or negative
one uh let's do a fast freway transform
on this
array there's a lot of signal processing
people that use one zero or negative one
for their signal the seism people do it
the Astro radio astronomy people do it
but then they want to do it to 64 bits
of per so this is the fast forward
transform of that random junk um I
didn't actually program any complex
numbers for for Julia uh for the for
these number system I got them for free
with Julia
um and what I'm going to do next is I'm
going to do this form and I'll go over
this formula real briefly what it does
is it's it's um it it takes the complex
difference between the the the the
result and what it started with P right
and the and the inverse fora transform
of the of the of the of the fora
transform uh array and then it takes the
uh complex distance of of that
difference and then it sums it together
so you can see this is basically a net
sum difference between it remember that
number it's
0.0022 let's do the same thing with uh
32-bit floating
points and
then I'm going to do the same thing here
except here I've already pre-done I've
done the I've done the 4A transform and
then done the inverse 4A transform
uh and you can see that this is not as
good point
in five times bigger
area so one question is does this have
any like real world implications so I
will go ahead and load a library from
Julia and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to the details of this aren't
important but I'm going to record some
sound uh from um the computer uh any any
anyone want to give me a word to say
real quick before I let this go
okay I'll do it in honor of Rex
Computing since they're
here Rex
Computing Rex Computing all
right that transformed forward and back
that we just heard uh no that's that's
just what I recorded to prove that to
prove that I've done it get a little
clipping there um so now I'm going to uh
uh write this formula here and uh this
function here and uh basically um what
just happened here okay
uh oh this is a very brave demo I must
say oh hold on
sorry oh no I accidentally didn't hit
enter when I did that so I'm going to
copy I'm going to copy the data so that
I don't lose it first uh and then I'm
going to do this uh do this function
here which will um which will basically
uh take the function do the fora
transform the inverse 4A transform
return it back to float 32 and then and
then output that as as a result buffer
and you're doing that with floats first
uh uh no this is I'm I'm going to do
this in um oh and note that it takes T
which is going to be a data type so I
can specify the data type when I call
this
function okay so um first I'm going to
do it with uh with um 8 bit posits 8 bit
yeah
it's also going to Output how how far
away it is and the net different
difference is
169 and now we can listen to it Rex
Computing not so bad um now I'm going to
also load up a a custom library that I
wrote called alt FP and what that is
it's an alternate small floating Point
uh floating Point Library um this this
provides ability to custom generate um a
floating points of of varying sizes um
in this case I'm going to do um small
float 8 comma 3 um so let's do this um
which means that it's an 8bit float uh
with only three bits of exponent you're
going to have to trust me that that's
better than
four
uh and then you can see already that the
N that there's a numerical difference
180. 925 instead of 160 n so this is
slightly worse also uh this doesn't have
nens so I just let it you know I'm doing
the thing which we do with posits make
it a little bit Fair more fair and so
this is what it sounds like I don't know
if you can hear the difference because
when I tried this it was kind of an an
noisy environment but Rex Computing yeah
maybe you can't really hear it but
nonetheless for 8 bit for8 bit you know
um encodings is not not not doing so
poorly but you did get a a Superior
Sound difference in one of your
experiments with posits they sounded
better uh it was it actually the other
way but that's cuz I converted negative
numbers wrong okay okay all right so uh
so okay so the next anyway you can do
fast for transforms they're they're more
accurate using posits than they are than
they are using um than they are using uh
floating point or floating Point sty
numbers okay so the next thing I'm going
to talk about is machine learning um
which as you might know is a pretty hot
thing right now um I apologize this part
might take a little bit of time so um so
a key a key thing that you can do with
these is to do a an ex a a a exor the
top bit and left shift and I you know I
was going to do maybe some sort of like
interactive uh thing where we try and
figure out what that does but I'm low on
time so let's let's just do let's just
do it this way so I'm going to show you
that uh this in fact does what you
expect it to
do so it's going to exort the top bit
and then left shift right so it ex exort
the top bit and left shifted
too uh and then also
um let's see
uh Let's do let's do one that's not
negative
oops got this problem
bits that's the sigmoid function you
need for deep learning imagine when it's
takes to compute that with a floating
Point call to a library to do eus X and
of course a divide withits it's it's you
flip the first bit and shift to right
two places and you've got almost a
perfect approximation of that function
which is why Isaac started calling them
sigmoid numbers they're just made it's
like they were tailor made for neural
networks okay this this I forgot to
execute plot at the beginning to get to
get this to run faster oh and oh so you
can so you can actually see this plot
right here so that that's what this
thing looks like it has the same it has
the same uh slope um as as as the either
the one 1 over 1 plus eus X so the
natural question is can you actually use
this for for machine learning okay so uh
and and are there some sort of are there
like advantages that you can take
advantage of because um uh because of
their nature um so I'm going to uh open
up a library that I wrote called gen ml
which is kind of a very early stage
General machine learning um uh machine
learning package um and then here I'm
going to define something um a posit a
16-bit posit I'm going to call it
MLP um and what I'll do now is I will uh
Define this function um which will it's
going to be a Boolean function that
takes a vector of of of 10 of 10 10
Boolean variables and then calculates a
Boolean formula on it and then scrambles
and then scrambles it uh 5% of the time
so this is kind of like you know a
really cheesy version of some sort of
noisy data that you might use for
machine learning so in this case I'm
going to so the dollar sign is exor um
exor is very important because it's not
easy to do uh you require it requires
multiple layers in in in a neuron net to
get an exor to work so it's going to be
V3 or V4 exor with
V1 okay and and uh a couple of
housekeeping things that I have to do
I'm going to assign
um assign in the monkey patch in in the
in the Gen ml Library a couple of
functions so instead of a sigmoid I'm
going to do use the pseudo logistic
function which is exor top bit and left
and and right shift
two um okay uh and then a couple more
things I'm going to do is I'm going
to and we have had a hard stop at 5:45
but sorry just the cameras go off we
have an internal session afterwards you
can tell us
to We have forever okay great uh so so
here I'm generating a a 500 data set
array of random bus and then solving
them through the the noisy function to
get a set of training results and then
uh uh sorry setting up a training
results array and then and then um and
then and then doing solving the function
f for that for those um for those values
and then populating the training results
okay the next thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to create a multi-layer
perceptron
um that I'll call demonet and note that
this takes values uh everywhere you can
see this posit 16 Z which means it's
acting on on this 16bit posit everywhere
so all the data in here is a 16 is 16bit
posits um
all right so then I have this function
of train with the result that I'm going
to copy in I'm just showing it to you so
that you know I'm being honest and not
doing anything sketchy um but uh this is
what it looks like it it basically does
30 rounds of batch of batch training
with the entire data set as the batch
and then at the end it tests and outputs
uh outputs the percentage it got correct
uh based off of testing 50 random 50
random values okay so let's do this
let's see what happens what happens when
we when we train train this guy
okay excellent so I got 98% correct um I
will um you know I will generate a
random I will generate a random uh
Boolean array um and what was the
formula the formula was uh V1 xor V3 V3
or V4 so V3 or V4 is going to be uh
false or true which is going to be true
and then V1 is false so that's going to
be uh false exort true so the answer
should be true unless this is in the 2%
of Errors let's see what
happens oops right we need to sorry we
need to convert that from not being not
being a posit into being a Boolean this
is almost like you know which
not so it evaluated correctly good I can
I can I can I can breathe a little bit
easier here I I say this a brave demo so
I'm going to do this again except
instead of doing um 16 bits I let's do
it with 8 Bits And what do you think
will
happen yeah it won't get 98% but you
might get pretty
good okay so now this is the same thing
except except with 8 bit posits all
right um so if I actually go ahead and
train this it's going to get me no
better than
random yeah okay so that's that's that's
a problem that's too small okay so uh
how how can we fix this
problem well maybe we can do it by
increasing the bit size so something
catastrophic happens between between 16
bits and8 bits that make makes this not
work
anymore all right um unfortunately I
have to exit Julia and bring it back up
because
otherwise otherwise it will it will not
know that I'm handle what I'm about to
do well um so I'm going to do all the
same things I'm going to redefine all
these all the things that I just uh
defined
um uh so basically I've redefined f um
I've I've imported all the libraries
assigned the sigmoid values uh generated
the input Matrix and the training
results uh and then this time I've set
it to a z just like before um and then
i' I've created the new demo net and
populated with random random
variables
oh where did I mess up darn why don't
you just tell us how many bits it takes
okay we'll trust you uh right so so the
the key point is that all you have to do
is monkey patch the outer product and
let the outer outer product be a 16bit
outer product and then magically
everything works just one just one
function okay in in the process and uh
and um yeah so when you do that uh when
you do that it just it's able to it's
able to train correctly fantastic so if
you could use eight bits instead of 16
bits you could go twice as fast as even
these special purpose Hardware things
that they're building to do oh I see
where the problem
is so how do you figure out
what that was by trial and error and the
way that I did it was first I did it
with the 16bit uh uh posits and then at
at every stage of the machine learning
process I constricted the 16bit pro uh
um posits and and and trim them down to
eight bits and then I found the one
place that was critical and then I did
the inverse experiment which is to take
eight bit posits and then see if I just
expanded to 16 bit posits in that one
place it's trivial right there the
representation is identical so
internally Julia doesn't know it's
treating everything as as a 64-bit int
uh under the hood but it just doesn't
truncate and round yeah um so so the so
the so the interesting thing is that you
know this could be a way to make uh um
um U machine learning much more
efficient um so actually if I I think
one of the first places these things
might show up is in gpus because as long
as it's putting the right pixels on the
screen no one cares what the format is
to a large extent I I tried to get AMD
interested in it but that was before AMD
finally had some cash on hand and they
couldn't do anything so maybe can
so actually I I'm pretty sure this will
work so so here's here's here's monkey
patching the um that one uh function um
you can see I've added these uh these
widen uh directives here which will
widen the values at at this one place
where it's doing the matrix
multiplication okay um and then so it
gives me warnings CU I'm monkey patching
a function and then if we train
this now remember everything's still
eight bits 90% not
bad yeah maybe
acceptable all right I think that
concludes our talk sorry to go for
here thank
you so now we can do questions and
discussion and you can tell me why this
will never work which is
yes um say he's good we he slides up
within an hour uhhuh great I thought he
disted them ahead of time so people
could follow along it'll be on it'll be
on second now okay good so yes so I have
several algorithms that require that I
be able to control the rounding
direction if I don't then the men could
cross the Max and then they don't work
so um that's a that's a significant
thing to CR well I think as soon as you
have start getting into things like that
that says you need valid not floats in
other words don't use posits use valids
there's all this machinery for doing
wonderful calculations that that and and
and that's all developed you know like I
say the other thing is the other thing
is um I've successfully used the um
overflow and underflow sticky bits to
run the fast algorithm check the bit and
only if it had an overflow and underflow
rerun with the SL algor I've done
that and I'm a big believer in that that
kind of runtime control as well and I've
used NS to avoid exceptions in the
middle of expensive calculations yeah I
think we we do need a way that you can
keep on going let's say you're doing a
just a whole list of calculations and
only one of them is bad you want some
way of being able to continue to proceed
throwing out that one about the number
format that there are features in the I
that are there for a good reason yes I
just don't want to keep feeding a nan as
an input into a floating Point
Unit possible yeah conventional rounding
in Fastway transform introduces a bias
do you have a way of changing that to
say random rounding which is it how is
it biased if you're uh let's see if
you're uh is your signal has a DC level
yes oh yeah we we've run into that
um let's see that's a tough question uh
I was using experiments where there was
no DC level and I wasn't running into it
so if you're rounding if you're doing
you're saying round to nearest even
introduces a bias I'm just saying
rounding the conventional rounding
introduces a bias which can be
eliminated by doing a random rounding up
or
down instead of round to nearest
even it add to the noise being PC down
yeah that's a tough one I'll have to
think that one
through yes um you said that that
project can be used as a drop in for
floating point and I'm trying to
understand what that means because if I
write a floating Point uh library and I
had to pay attention to all have to add
Logic for all the the underflows and
overflows and NS and so on so that
software won't work exactly with posits
what do you you won't get any NS you
won't get any overflows you won't get
any underflows and your answer will be
more accurate in that sense it's a drop
in uh so all the exceptions you put in
to handle bad things code you have to be
the only thing that could go wrong is if
you say if number bigger than two to the
you know whatever and you got some magic
numbers where you want to let's say say
trunk 8 to zero then those would
probably have to be changed if you've
hardwired things into your function and
I know let's say if you've got a routine
for computing uh cosine of x and you've
got the polinomial coefficient slid out
I I think You' probably want different
polinomial coefficients for
approximating cosine if you had posits
and if you wanted floats but in general
there's nothing to do with um interval
arithmetic where you would have to do
tiling methods or watch watch for
expansion and things like that that's
why I'm saying it's same algorithms
would
work so as I showed in My Demo when I
did the fastb transform with 32 bits
floats versus 32 deposits that did not
Branch off into two different two
different like you know
yeah logic in there for Point anomalies
anyway the process was identical the
thing that the computer I mean obviously
to actually do the adds subtracts and
multiplies you know there were different
there there there's no right but like
the actual outer the outer algorithm was
identical if you wanted to convert the
nag Library over it wouldn't be that
hard to convert it to posits it' be if
anything you you take code out because
you wouldn't need it anymore and it
would just get yeah the era you reported
for the fast 48 transform uh comparison
sort of brushed over what could have
been some
serious minor uh spotty errors did you
make any calculations to show the
maximum error in the two different
calculations that's a very good point uh
I just finished the fast for transform
yesterday so not yet yeah you do
experiments first and you follow more
theoretical underpinnings and try to
figure out well is this just luck or is
this always going to happen then you get
some proofs as to what's the worst thing
that can happen we haven't done that yet
so when you talked about the it floating
Point giving different answers on
different machines yes um was that using
multiply ad and double extended or was
that just the straight standard one of
the first places that happens is if one
uses fuse multiply add and the other one
doesn't for example but if one has an 80
bit accumulator let's say because it's
got 87 and the other one does not then
you got problems there that's why the
standard didn't include the 80 bit reg
in the registers and multiply ad is
actually not allowed by the standard
unless you call it a multiply ad you see
you do init
arithmetic the compiler in in posit
arithmetic should not be allowed to
replace a multiply and an ad by a
multiply ad without per explicit
permission by the user it's a different
function just as Fus dot product is a
different function but the I standard
itself doesn't include it and that's
just an that's just it there's a whole
lot of things in the it standard where
they were not thinking about making
bitwise compatibility and you can add
them on and and and fix that yes my
question was going to be the same thing
this may be a semantic issue and so that
doesn't apply but it sounds like what
you're saying if you do things that are
beyond the scope of the original H
standard and get results the original it
standard wouldn't allow you to get those
results might not be the same I mean to
the if you were not allowed to extend
the standard to do things like the fuse
multiply ad would it still give you
potentially different results on
different machines or are those
differences because the machines took
liberties with the standard why is this
uh okay the the reason the standard
gives differences is because it has
options as to what you can what you must
do and what you might want to do okay
that's what I wantah runs his algorithms
without any of the options he I run him
with all the options but he wanted he
was he was interested in letting people
improve the results any way they can so
if One processor said can I use a couple
of guard bits here and keep them through
all the calculation and only round when
I hit the equal sign he said yeah yeah
I'll give better answers but every user
I know is really upset when they get a
different answer and they don't know
which one is the better answer they just
know they're different and is it a bug
is it a rounding error
pain
yeah the reason I was queuing in on that
is one of the early Intel
microprocessors that implemented the
fused op ad was the
i860 machine oh yeah I remember 89 time
frame yep and there are people who have
said that one reason that didn't succeed
better is because they took this
particular Liberty with the putting wi
standard and thus people did not get the
same results and whether that was an
issue or not or whether it was
Improvement or not the fact that it was
different was a Target that people could
throw at them here multiply these
numbers and you'll see that it didn't
work right you might also remember the
early days of the sea language when it
was first introduced the the rule was
that as you entered a routine with
floats they were automatically pres
promoted to doubles and people said how
do we turn that off because they did not
want it happening without their control
if they wanted doubles they're going to
ask for doubles and but it's going to be
so much better you're going to get
double Precision it'll be great no they
don't stop helping stop helping we'll do
it you know if we want it we'll do it
IBM had the same issue on the 360 series
with the 36 6091 to get a pipeline
divide they actually did worse rounding
sometimes a very small percentage of the
time and it meant the nuclear industry
couldn't buy that machine but the
scientific Computing people were very
happy because pipeline divides ran quite
fast yeah well partial accumulation was
a quick way
of U saving memory for a lot of stuff
yeah but you know you're you had good
arguments on your your first two
arguments at the beginning do this
there's actually a third problem which
is in the ACM undergraduate
curriculum uh the curriculum is only one
quarter for numerical methods I'm
surprised there's that yeah no actually
home State University in the country in
the world you can get a degree in
computer science without ever touching
numerical analysis that's that's right
and actually a lot of that has to be
complaints by students who find
discussions about floating Point like
this exceedingly boring I had I had a
three quter numerical methods class
myself and well when I teach parallel
processing I teach them with things that
round and I I write in their face they
get different answers when they group
things in parallel instead of doing them
serly from left to right uh and they
usually do not get taught that in most
universities because it's an ugly
example so I think you need a third
slide basically saying we have we have
to change the thinking in a lot of Cs
departments well maybe I mean I I when I
debated Khan last July he's of the U
opinion that the whole world has to
change so that we go back to analyzing
every single line of code for a
surrounding error all you know 10
million lines of code that you've got
you have to analyze every single one and
everybody's a bad person if they does
don't do that I I don't think it's going
to happen I think even fewer people are
doing numerical analysis now than the
were 10 years ago even fewer than 20
years ago and we have to find ways to
make it more automatic and higher
quality there there is a difference
between numerical analysis and numerical
methods yeah when I taught numerical
methods I didn't teach why the
algorithms would fail I taught them how
to figure out when the algorithms would
fail but not through the proofs but just
by a higher you know a simpler analysis
like turn down the Precision until it
fails or something like that you didn't
have to go that far but so way numerical
analysis is a very mathematical
discipline yes numerical methods can be
taught as a more engineering approach
right I I completely agree and you might
be able to get away with teaching that
and getting some more literacy in that
that's but there aren't that many
numeric analysts out there yes getting
away from the technology in theory
what's driving you to do this your love
of numbers or is there some business
opportunity here what not for the money
that's for sure I mean that's why I'm
giving it all away although I I'm
discovering I'm making more money on
Consulting than I ever would do probably
if I were Tred to charge license or
royalty fee so I you don't if you're
trying to introduce a new number system
you don't fine people for using it right
they're never going to touch it but uh I
think my royalties on this been almost a
dollar an hour now for minimum as
minimum wage price so CU it
yeah I'm G tell Dave Bailey you know he
needs to look at the what you just
presented if he does you have to talk to
Dave already well Dave baile was one of
the reviewers of the book yeah yeah so
you know and also one of my other former
co-workers who who used to do a lot of
cfd and you know they there's
communities that appreciate this the Cs
Community tends to appreciate less
though so what really motivated me
mainly was at Intel we were trying to
get to exos scale Computing and I was on
the leading the research group trying to
drive that and we quickly identified
that the pathway between D and processor
was going to use 100 megawatts all by
itself and we're limited to 20 megawatts
for an exus scale comp supercomputer so
if you can't get that down by technology
Trends just saying well you know
memory's getting low lower power because
it wasn't the trends were not going to
get it down below 100 megawatts in in
the foreseeable future use fewer bits
make them more meaningful and it might
cost you more transistors on chip I said
you might make a much more complicated
uh uh FPU but it'll pay you could maybe
use three times as many transistors on
the FPU but make every bit count and
you'd win because you'd be moving far
fewer bits and you'd be able to get away
with single Precision instead of double
Precision everywhere we throw 64-bit
Precision at everything these days and
that's one thing that's stopping us
getting to exis scale so that's what
really motivated me was was trying to
get past the memory wall problem but I'm
always attracted to a problem where I
see there's a better solution but
everybody's doing it this way cuz that's
the way we've always done it and that
was the way with parallel processing in
the 80s we could see that parallel
processing was a great thing but hey you
you you know it's you have to change all
your code and it's already already
written and optimized for these Vector
machines and it's not going to happen
but it did happen I love i' love to see
those revolutions where it just goes to
the breaking point suddenly everybody's
doing it in the new way so what what
between the original UNS and posits is
that that the posits are array friendly
because you you pick a fixed size for
them um what about the the number of
Cycles to do uh say multiply or divide
is that now constant yeah all posits
just like it is with floats so so it's
also kind of GPU friendly that is very G
friendly very Rex friendly theyve got a
vliw they need to know exactly how many
clock Cycles everything takes so yeah
you don't have and the the lack of
handling should help you you have just
two exception numbers zero and plus or
minus infinity those are the only two
you have to watch out for and you do
those off to the side while you're going
ahead the only thing I would caveat it
with is my multiplier is going to be
slightly bigger because I get a little
bit more Precision so like in a double
Precision number 64 bits 61 of them
might be the
fraction if you have an es of zero so
you might need 122 bit multiplier in
order to be able to do to round
correctly and that's a little bit bigger
than 106 bit multip lier that you need
right now but I'm I'm pretty sure that's
not going to swell the the Silicon area
of the FPU that by that much you've got
a lot of other logic that you've got to
worry about in a an
FPU except taking exceptions out yeah
taking exceptions out is is a very
helpful thing you guys should go have
dinner with John now on Stanford so
let's go din all right let's do dinner
thanks very
much